Leon: Given the record of the past, God knows,
10, 15 years, where is the hope?
Does it all seem hopeless and yet you continue
your work?
Vladimir: Well, first of all, let's just get
one thing clear.
There hasn't been a free and fair election
in Russia in at least 16 years.
In these regional elections, for instance
last year, the People's Freedom Party was
prevented from participating in the elections
in Novosibirsk, in Kaluga, in Magadan, initially
in Novgorod.
And this is the usual picture.
You have to understand that as a rule, genuine,
real opposition to the Kremlin is not even
allowed to formally participate in the election
process, and we're off the ballot ahead of
time.
In those few instances when the opposition
is allowed to be on the ballot, we scored
pretty good results such as when Boris Nemtsov
won his legislative seat in Yaroslavl in 2013
when Alexei Navalny received, even according
to official results, nearly 30% of the vote
in Moscow in the mayoral election in 2013.
So, basically elections in Putin's Russia
has been turned into a meaningless ritual
to formalize the regime and to continue its
stay in power.
However, we believe, and I believe, and this
is also from historical experience, that boycotts
and passive posture never work.
And I think we have to use, even this bogus
and sham and watered-down election process,
as it exists today, in order to try to get
our message across to as many of our compatriots
as we can, and also to help young up and coming
political opposition, civil society activists
to gain some political experience by participating
in these campaigns, to gain some reputation,
to gain name recognition.
So, for instance, the Open Russia Movement,
of which I'm the national coordinator, has
tried twice already last year.
First on the municipal level in St. Petersburg,
and then on the regional level in Novosibirsk
to support candidates.
In both times, candidates whom we supported,
even again according to the official results,
came in second place with more than 20% of
the vote.
This is a really far cry from the 1.5% or
2% for the opposition and the Kremlin would
like people to believe.
So this year we're preparing to support 10,
15, maybe 20 candidates for the State Duma
in single-member districts across Russia,
mostly in big cities of course, but still
across Russia, we're not talking about just
Moscow, in order again to get our message
across, this pro-democracy, pro-European alternative
message to what the Kremlin is offering to
as many people as we can, and to help our
supporters, young opposition and civil society
activists, to gain this experience.
Because nothing is forever and this regime
is not forever, and there will come a time
when new generation of pro-democracy Russians
will have to take responsibility for the country
and we want to start getting them ready for
that today.